tout ce que j'aurais pu imaginer que le
film ressemble juste en lisant le
scénario pâle par rapport à la
vie réelle que Luke a insufflé dans ce
projet et en prenant plaisir à faire des films
qui aiment un écrivain très impressionnant,
un système de rêve très facile à vivre, je pense qu'il
pourrait produire  financièrement ce filme
tout seul mais je pense qu'il aime avoir
quelqu'un mais plus tôt je peux
avoir différents points de vue je pense que
nous sommes une bonne équipe
la chose la plus intéressante à propos de travailler
avec Luke est qu'il est le caméraman son
réalisateur qui  connaît précisément chaque
petit élément de son cadre, c'est un
type de personnage formidable parce qu'il
sait ce qu'il voit dans son esprit et veut
que cette vision soit parfaitement exécutée et
vous pouvez le voir dans la façon dont il
utilise la caméra et comment moi-même et
l'autre  acteurs mais j'apprécie que
dans un réalisateur j'adore ça donc je veux essayer
de faire de mon mieux partout et j'aime
être très proche des acteurs c'est pourquoi
j'ai la caméra sur sho  Ulder je ne coupe pas
et ils apprécient beaucoup parce que
toute cette partie avant l'action est l'endroit où
ils doivent préparer l'homme s'ils doivent faire
ça toutes les trente secondes, c'est juste
épuisant pour eux, surtout avec
Scarlett, elle est incroyable à chaque fois que nous avons
partagé des scènes  avec émotion et ça
doit venir tout le monde était là mais les
deux seuls étaient quand ils se regardaient c'était
elle et fait et tu sens juste
qu'elle est prête et tu veux juste être là
pour elle tu veux juste dire oh elle est
prête
ton désir  c'est comme toutes les choses qui
font de nous des
connaissances communautaires sur tout
je ne sais pas quoi en faire je serai
à ta porte dans 12 heures